[Music]
[Applause]
Adam DeVine set to join us he stars in
The Outlaws on Netflix that premieres
July 7th and uh continues to star and
the righteous gemstones on HBO Max and
Adam DeVine actor comedian joining us on
the program how's your morning going
Adam
yeah I'm okay Dan thanks for asking okay
I'm here and in the neighborhood there
could be issues so I just want to make
sure everything's good yeah I'm I'm
doing okay my neighbor is doing some
construction and I thought I might need
to uh get violent but I don't think so I
think he's playing it cool okay are you
more famous than your neighbor
than my uh that one yeah I think he's an
orthopedic surgeon
well you're always in a good mood you're
a funny guy so I he's more useful I'm I
might be more famous he's definitely
more useful okay but but you could could
you be mad where you with your face as
an actor like you're you're used to you
know fun guy
I want to get that role where everyone's
like oh he's just an affable man
everybody likes this guy and then
something clicks and I'm gonna go past
uh yeah I'm not they're not knocking my
door down to give me that role so okay
actor comedian or comedian actor
uh however you want to say it no but how
do you want me to say it uh you know I
you can act to a community it doesn't it
really doesn't matter I I love being a
comedian so if if you say comedian actor
I'm perfectly happy I was wondering how
to freeze this and my guys kept saying I
was saying it wrong
you got a funny face
from the standpoint of when you come on
I laugh
so is that a is it a compliment just or
should I say it in a different way that
you have a like Will Ferrell has a funny
face when he's on Jack Black funny face
we all are inflicted with the same
disease of funny face syndrome uh you
know I I I've had that my entire life
and there was a time that I thought I
might do something else with my life uh
and then enough adults told me that I
have a funny face I'm like I think I
have to get into comedy there's no other
path for me
okay but is that a compliment or should
I should I come up with a better way
it's not a compliment oh I'm offended
but I'm playing it cool okay uh no it's
okay I'm I'm fine well you make me laugh
every time I see you and then you come
up on screen and you steal the scene
well thank you Dan yeah no I uh I think
another phrase for it is punchable face
or they want to hit me when's the last
time you were in a fight I just want to
squish that face
it's it's been it's been a while now
yeah
I uh I I trained at this boxing gym here
in Hollywood and uh my first training
partner was Randy Couture
the UFC fighter oh yeah and uh he didn't
take it easy on me I think he didn't
think I had a funny face I think he
thought I had a punchable face and and
it was for sure well you could use
comedy to disarm him that's right I
could I could have but I couldn't look
up I was just trying to duck and cover
at that point uh I want you to listen if
I do a voiceover you know you always
have in a world you know those guys so
if I'm gonna promote the Outlaws
Owen Browning is a straight laced bank
manager about to marry the love of his
life Parker when his bank is held up by
the infamous ghost Bandits during his
wedding week he believes his future
in-laws who just arrived in town are the
infamous Outlaws
Dan quit your job right now I've got a
gig for you you are a voice over
assassin my friend that was great yeah
okay Phyllis fill us in on the movie
because Ellen Barkin and Pierce Brosnan
play play your uh you're in yes so they
play they play my in-laws they come into
town I'm a bank manager I'm pretty
buttoned up and uh they're just wild
they come in well wearing their cool
Leathers having their cool faces and
they take me out we party I go skydiving
I get a tattoo I'm like a ton of things
I wouldn't do I go into work the next
morning I'm talking to Lil Rel who works
for me at the bank and I'm like man this
is the best night of my life my in-laws
are so great I just I am a little
hungover I need a nice chill day here at
work click click there's a gun to my
head and two people are robbing my bank
and as they leave they say something
that leads me to believe that
um that it's my in-laws
owing someone some money like in heat
where they have like someone that cleans
their money for them and uh we stole it
from me and uh they they owe this person
like five million dollars and that
person
kidnaps my fiance and now I have to team
up with my in-laws to try to get my
fiance back and that's that's really the
movie he's Adam DeVine the uh Outlaws on
Netflix premieres July 7th and continues
to be a star in the righteous gemstones
on HBO Max what do people say to you
they see you on the street what's the
first thing that you know you're
probably going to get
I mean it depends on their age uh if
they're young if they're
uh I would say pitch Perfect's probably
the most and then and then Workaholics
in Modern Family is uh is a close second
I would say but I get I get a lot of
people that are just like sing for me
sing like I'm trying to eat eggs this is
omelette time this isn't time for
crooning but but you you can sing but
Pitch Perfect you have to sing
I do have to sing yeah that's it's
mandatory yeah yeah but your love you
you and Rebel Wilson have become you
know like Sandler and Drew Barrymore you
know we we kind of I was just texting
with uh Rebel this morning oh yeah she's
doing great yeah
um what was the comedy that you saw and
you go this is what I want to do or was
it stand up or was it a movie
you know what it kind of was
uh and this maybe is bad maybe I
shouldn't be saying this but I I when I
was a kid I watched evening at The
Improv do you remember that show yeah it
was it was it was just at the Improv
here on Melrose uh in Hollywood and they
just had Comics come up every night and
they called it evening at the emperor
they did like 200 episodes of it and
when I was a kid my Dad loved watching
it and I remember watching it wasn't
like the Chris rocks or the like super
famous people that for sure are gonna go
on and be icons in the in the business
it was the guys that weren't that good
that I was like well I can do that
I can be I can be I can be mediocre
and that's what inspired me so I'm
hoping my career inspires uh some other
you know
I can do that if he can
yeah if he can do it I can for sure do
it well it was that and then watching
you know I love Adam Sandler and Chris
Farley and that was kind of my
generation of SNL people and like what
Sandler's been able to build making all
these movies casting his friends kind of
keep pulling back to the the the talent
well of all of his friends from SNL is
um kind of my dream what I would like to
end up doing and the he uh dream come
true was my producing partner on the
Outlaws so it really oh that's awesome
yeah yeah it was pretty incredible well
you know I've been in some Sandler
movies
I do know this yes yeah
I mean you may not know I'm that good of
an actor that that was me in those
movies
which which movie where was it I might
have just lied to you
um I've been in 20 of them Adam
you've been in 20 of his movies
grown-ups grown-ups too Just Go With It
Longest Yard
why is it I did my homework on you and
you didn't do your homework that's
hey well Dan it's because I'm good I'm
about to do 25 of these today how many
how many interviews are you doing today
just you
just you okay all right okay all right
fair enough uh how important is Nebraska
Football in your life
I mean I I yes they're the best I love
them and national championships this
year
[Laughter]
if you could be nominated for an Academy
Award
or Nebraska
could be in the national title game
what would you take well I'm a selfish
little prick myself but I respect that I
respect myself but I mean they've won
titles oh long time you weren't even
born then I was born I was a I was a
young boy but I was there I'm telling
you all right yeah I mean that was like
right when I had just moved my family
moved to Omaha in 1994. yeah and that
was kind of that was the start of our
real run and uh Tommy Frazier
uh yeah I didn't know we could lose I
was like this is just how it goes
I moved to the big city of Omaha
Nebraska and uh your your college
football team just wins did you drive by
Warren Buffett's house
yeah oh yeah yeah and you look at it and
you go
I could do that I know I could buy that
I could buy that yeah yeah uh good luck
with the Outlaws good luck good luck
with uh the righteous gemstones and and
once again when your face comes on
camera it's not a funny face you just
are funny when there's a compliment in
there somewhere and look when we hang up
and then you say to your publicist what
an ass did you hear what he said okay no
my publicist is yeah he's nodding his
head yes okay fair enough he's like
funny it's funny
hey thank you great to talk to you Adam
thank you so much Dan Adam DeVine okay I
I said this yesterday when I see his
face it makes me laugh he's got a funny
face